this is all that remains of
eight-year-old hannah's house
she lives in the neighborhood of
bobrawicza on the outskirts of chernhiv
there is no water electricity and gas no
one comes here and asks no one does
anything
she's not the only one to have lost her
home
her neighbor alexei serrada shows us
what was once his pride and joy
all that's left are the ashes of a
previous life
his home was first hit by russian bombs
in the early days of the war and again
on the 10th of march
now i have nothing the ceiling and
floors are burnt the most painful thing
is that all my memorable documents have
burnt
i didn't need them but i kept them as
souvenirs i'm a retired pilot and i kept
all my pilot logs there
despite having lost all his possessions
he looks to the future with hope
come back in two years i will rebuild
everything we will have a barbecue
together
chernhee woke up to the rocket attacks
on the first day of the war when russian
troops crossed the border from belarus
despite being besieged it did not
surrender and finally on the 30th of
march the russian forces retreated from
the region
but chernhee has paid a high price
andriy and svetlana's home was hit three
times and now they are trying to salvage
whatever remains
you see how our russian brothers have
helped us
we met hannah again in a nearby shelter
they have shown me my room already it is
a nice room i will stay here as long as
i can i don't have a choice
our center was created for children with
psycho-neurological difficulties when
the bombing started many people came
here as they were looking for shelter we
became a shelter for those who needed it
for hannah it might not be an ideal
setup but at least she now has a roof
over her head
not only this rehab center for children
has changed after the war in ukraine
civilians are now becoming frontline
workers helping to rebuild the country
and they say in this process they are
more united than ever resourcer al
jazeera chernham